it's hello Bianca good to have you back
and have you started with any of the
posters on the portal I guess sonalika
has asked you to go through the biennial
course right
for the art coding course have you
started with those
hello
it's good to have you here can you let
me know uh what is your background as
well are you from a biology background
or from my computer science program
all right perfect
and do you have any specific research
interests
with respect to health informatics
[Music]
all right perfect
and uh what about rest of the parties
then
can you let me know about your
educational background as well are you
from a biology background or family
um
computer science background
I'm curious to know
um can you let me know like why have you
guys joined the program do you have any
specific
reason are you trying to learn machine
learning or what is your purpose or
motive behind joining the program
okay so Tariq Bashir says he has
completed Masters in public health
um he's doing Masters in public health
from Hyderabad Central University
and Krishna Kumar has joined the program
for Mentor guidance
all right perfect
can you also let me know like
or why have you joined today's program
do you have any specific research
interest in mind
okay he says I would like to explore
this emerging vertical in the field of
Public Health all right and have you
started with any of the courses on
moving subject learn portal or are you
here for the first time
okay so I'll walk you through a brief
demo on how you can sign up on the
portal and how you can take a look at
various courses that are there so that
you can
carry along with the program based on
your
research interests and I can say that a
couple more of participants have joined
uh it would be great if you could also
introduce yourselves in the chat box
foreign
machine learning and I am non-tech
background from accounts finance and the
bcom MBA and python training done and
data science now interested for machine
learning in healthcare that's very
impressive
um I'm curious to know like what made
you interested in the field of machine
learning for healthcare you can see that
you have a diverse range of background
from account Finance I'm curious to know
what made you interested in this field
uh you are interested because of the
many opportunities in healthcare okay
and I can see that um we also have many
familiar participants Among Us
I can see that uh you guys have joined
today's meeting as well
can you also let me know what made you
interested machine learning for health
informatics
is interested in
research on DNA specific virals that can
counter attack against potential
microorganisms so he is interested in
biology what about the rest of you guys
[Music]
all right so meanwhile other
participants uh join I'll quickly start
with the brief introduction uh so hello
everyone a very warm greeting to one and
all my name is and I would like to
welcome you all for the very first
session on machine learning for health
informatics program
for those of you who are new to the
program the machine learning for health
informatics has been designed for anyone
who is interested to learn about
applications of Health informatics
machine learning and artificial
intelligence to help address Global
health problems
and in today's session we will be
covering topics on AI in transforming
Healthcare investments in AI Healthcare
how data science transforming Healthcare
challenges and health informatics
predictive model workflow multi-modal
approach Precision management and
finally we'll be ending with a q a
discussion with the expert uh wherein we
are joined by Dr G Circle who is the
senior Advanced marriage scientist at
Luce data
also before we begin with today's
session let me also take a brief moment
to introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a USB bankmatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
applicable
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the owning Strategic
Training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and this training
has been completed by participants in
different specialization track that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science and even comprehensive training
on obix data analysis
and here you will be also getting access
to several of the resources on almost
logic omix logic is a portal for
practical and theoretical learning of
mathematics it takes a combination of
training module data analysis tools
curated project data set and interactive
sessions with mentors to give the
student a clear path of the Bloom's
taxonomy pyramid and no matter what the
user's initial experience but with
balanced marriages or mix logic is going
to be a very useful tool for gaining a
baseline knowledge of the theory behind
Prismatic analysis of large data set and
introduction to basic coding languages
like R and python or evening or even
beginning a data analysis project
and as part of the program you'll also
get access to several of the almost
started courses that consist of courses
on bioinformatics transition medicine
multi-ohmic that consists of genomic
transcriptomics epigenomics and data
science that tends to stop using are in
python as well as game informatics and
also survey example projects which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work users will also be given
directions to access the T by info
platform for biometric processing and
Analysis of data and different stages of
analysis will be performed in
protections on this multi Ormond
platform as you can see in the
presentation
so now to view the various courses and
example projects let us first sign up on
the almost logic loan portal I can see
that several of the participants have
already joined have already uh logged in
on the portal but for those participants
who are new
um let me take a brief moment to
show you how you can sign up on the
portal and navigate through the various
courses that are there
so I've pasted the link for signing up
on the portal in the chat box
so uh please visit the link and I will
walk you through so for those
participants who are new uh you can
simply click on the create an account
option that you see here and you can
simply sign up by entering your name
email ID password or you can also log in
using any of your social media accounts
and for those participants who already
have an account on the portal you can
simply click on login now option and
simply click on sign in so if you are
filtering any technical issues let me
know in the chat and I'll be happy to uh
guide you on how to sign up on the
portal I'll pause for a couple of
seconds so that the participants can
sign up
and once you have signed up please put a
yes in the chat box so that I know I can
proceed ahead
and if you have already signed up on the
portal also you can put a yes so that I
can get a fair amount of idea who have
signed up and dropped off
has everyone signed up please put a yes
in the chat box
all right so I'm going to proceed ahead
so if you're having any queries you can
let me know so once you sign in on the
portal you'll be able to see the various
courses and example projects that are
there and to navigate through the
various courses you can simply enter the
keyword that you're looking for for
instance most of the participants will
be interested in machine learning you
can simply enter the term that will show
you the various courses and example
projects that makes use of the machine
learning context so now coming to one of
the important part is you need to update
your account once you sign up on the
booklet so how do you do that you can
simply click on the icon that says
profile and here you will be uh asked to
upload your profile image you can edit
your bio you can edit your name please
make sure that it should be in proper
capitalization and you can also link
your social media handling well such as
in my case I've linked my LinkedIn
account apply so once done click on
update and that will get updated
so and the next part is the active data
where the program mentor and the
community manager will be tracking your
learning program and once you start
picking up any of the courses that will
be displayed under the core system and
once you complete a research project and
publish it on our portal that will be
displayed at the projects Tab and once
you enrolled for any of the programs
such as machine learning for health
informatics that will be displayed under
the programs
and finally once you complete the
required quizzes assignments and
activities you'll be able to receive
your certificates
so as the participants have no further
queries let us move on to the next
exciting part of today's webinar wherein
we are joined by Dr Ajit selkar for
those of you who are joining for the
first time let me introduce you to the
program enter Dr Ajit sarkar is the
physician scientist with a keen interest
in data analytics and Christian medicine
keep passionate about finding meaning
out of biomedical data and leveraging
them for better clinical out currently
working as a senior biomatic scientist
at elucidator I'm sure we will be able
to learn a lot from today's session and
with that I would like to pass on the
stage to Dr over to yourself
hello yes sir
thanks regarding for your kind words so
I've introduced this is the first
session of the course
which has been named as health
informatics and
so today we will just briefly touch upon
the background and
I will give the introduction of the
entire quotes and what are the key
things which we will be covering it in
the all the eight sessions eight twelve
sessions
so let me share my screen
is my screen visible
yes
so hello once again so uh today we will
be covering the overview of the course
which has been named as machine learning
in health informatics
so as you know it's really a booming
field right now it's
right now in a very embryonic stage
people that there are resources the
scope in the coming days but the filter
is not that much matured so that's why
we started we conceived the idea of
introducing the Young Generation the
graduates and some PhD students who are
currently in load PhD or those who are
in the early career stage of their
career to this particular course
so I will start about a brief
introduction about myself so
this is a brief uh a glimpse of my
journey so I basically come from a
clinical background
I Was
Made majorly involved in healthcare
delivery during my graduation and lived
in my clinical residency
so from the from that time only because
I had a knack of
quantitative Sciences so from there I
shifted gradually to the clinical
research now as my responsibilities of
healthcare delivery went down and the
healthcare research part went up
and for the last Almost for the last six
years I have been working in the domain
of informatics mainly covering
bioinformatics and Healthcare
informatics
so this is my journey so it has been six
years in the Academia by Academia I mean
undergrad and postgrad
then in research in my doctoral degree
for five years and for the last two
years in industry
so mainly I am involved in informatics
and data analytics in using biotech data
and Healthcare data for the last six to
seven years
okay
so this is actually the three
three big sections which
which gives an overview of my career so
in Academia I was I am majorly trained
on biology and Medicine the basics of
biology and Medicine
health and disease so how do we Define
health what is health what is disease
also clinical approach to medicine and
public health approach to medicine so
these are all mainly uh not quantitative
Sciences majorly qualitative Sciences
with some
guideline based or rule-based things
which we have to learn
it also gives gives a first a very first
hand understanding of the biology and
Medicine it clears the concepts and that
that that's how Academia actually helps
and helped me
during my research I gradually shipped
it to the quantitative Sciences so where
we quantify uh biology we quantify
medicine we quantify Health we quantify
disease and after that once we quantify
disease then you can predict disease we
can predict health so this quantitative
approach to medicine is what I learned
during my research career but again it
was mostly driven by academic interests
and so on now for the last two years I
actually work on industry Solutions now
where we actually Bridge the academic
expertise and research
to build a product or a solution now
this is where actually we translate the
knowledge and give it back to the
community community to the society to
the population
so and actually industry scale
Healthcare data sets these are very very
huge they need lots of computation so
you also need to be you need to have the
expertise of computational biology you
need to know the basics of programming
you need to know some advanced level
programming also and that's a big
requirement which we will also cover in
this course so we will give in the last
four six sessions we will cover some
Hands-On exercise where we will discuss
about about the two case studies and we
will walk you through the entire code
and the notebook and explain those
things and uh just to give a Hands-On
practical feeling
now to start with so AI in healthcare
it's it's actually right now it's not
that much of a
unknown thing people talked about it
people write about it and you can you we
come across news we come across news in
the media in the newspapers and websites
browsers but if you see it has majorly
increased from
took around six or seven years back so
this is from where the sort of A
disruption occurred where people started
to use Ai and machine learning and data
science to transform Healthcare
now if you notice the journey the
journey has been phenomenal so there has
been multi-fold increase in AI
in transforming Healthcare and there are
lots and lots of places where AI is
being used today and that it's a very
it's a very diverse field it's a very uh
chaotic field Healthcare and Healthcare
data but again the data amount is going
to increase exponentially and as the
data amount increases as the
computational power increases of the
hardware and software hence the
requirement of trained resources who are
who are well comfortable with handling
Healthcare data in building models there
is a there is an enormous scope of this
particular
field so there are so to just to give an
overview I have just broken them into
six big fields and this actually is a
server done by health health and
McKenzie and they have just identified
that the the resource requirement which
is going to emerge in the coming future
so uh we will be requiring chronic Care
Management because as you know there is
a the uh there's something called
demographic transition so there's
something called The Pyramid so there is
a Young Generation there is a adult
generation there's an old generation so
now what is happening there is a
demographic transition where the number
of the geriatric population of the adult
and old population it's increasing
gradually and with these adult
population geriatric population
is there something called increased life
expectancy so increased life expectancy
with a huge burden of geriatric
population will
generate the need of chronic Care
Management
and so this is a very and chronic care
has lots of data and all these data can
be used
can be used to build models and so on
now next is self-care
so silkyard again comes with Chronicle
and self-care is is majorly for
prevention
and for wellness
and then is triage and diagnosis so we
know that the number of
the patients the number of
the the hospital bed accommodation and
the requirement those are increasing
very rapidly and that we have to do some
patient stratification
we have to do some triage and diagnosis
and that's where we need to merge
multiple types of data we need to merge
Healthcare data lab data then data from
Pharmacy records data from genetic
records and to build some triage
mechanism some statistical mechanism
next is Diagnostics so by Diagnostics we
mean actually
how do we diagnose a disease via some
kids via some x-ray images so these are
also increasing because nowadays
everybody likes to do a do our
Diagnostic and actually diagnosis
is a much more objective thing compared
to a subjective decision and so we also
have a great emphasis on automating
diagnosis to to give automated reports
so nowadays ECG already comes with the
automated report now x-rays will also
come with the automated report now those
reports have to be verified by the
doctor or the physician but it would
give a starting point and would help in
free Aging in making the process much
more fast
and of course clinical relation support
this can be in ICU care in internship
Care Unit you can you can design you can
recommend some drugs for particular
diseases with some comorbid conditions
so it's a very complex area clinical
decision support and Care delivery is
suppose how do we coordinate care so
healthcare for healthcare we have to
coordinate between the nut cells and
Physicians and the paramedics and the
pharmacy person
and maybe the relatives so how do we
coordinate the game so all these things
actually in bits and pieces they they
are the bits of bits and pieces of the
entire Healthcare uh puzzle and
informatics is slowly slowly growing in
this field and it and it will actually
[Music]
show its its potential once uh what's
the resources and everything becomes
much more uh available
so if we talk about the investments in
AI for healthcare so here I have just
shown the top 50 companies and
the amount of Revenue which they have
generated just for
introducing AI in healthcare and you can
see there is a lots of almost 8.5
billion of uh venture capitalist funding
in 50 best funded AI companies
and the top 50s so the top 50 has
reported close to 8.5 billion and the
top 10 has almost close to 5 Min 5
billion and nowadays uh big companies
like Google then Amazon they are also
they're also introducing their foot into
the domain of AI into the can
so now how did how data science can
transform Healthcare as such
so so the first thing which comes to our
mind when we talk about health is
patient and so we have to we have to
cater much more precise and
much more appropriate patient care so
suppose for a patient a patient can have
a management date uh have an appointment
date have a visited now there is
something called when is the pending
appointment so what should the what
should be the next visit date now this
date actually doctors prescribe on the
basis of some suppose one month two
months three months there are some rules
but can these next visit date can be
more precise
depending on the historical records can
you predict that this patient actually
needs a visit after 25 days
or after 60 days or after 30 days and
accordingly if we can
distribute and coordinate all the
patients for a particular healthcare
system for a nursing home or hospital or
for a city or for a village so that the
appointment times also decreases and the
visits are very uh coordinated
happen so as to ensure that each patient
get the maximal benefit of care
now next is precise Diagnostics so again
precise diagnostic so one person can
have diabetes or hypertension now that
person can also have some
genetic
genetic perturbation some mutation and
so it may be the case that that person
one drug One Drug would be would not be
helping that person because that person
has that particular genetic mutation so
if we can if we have the knowledge of
that genetic mutation and if you can
incorporate that in the clinical
predictive decision making then you can
build much more precise Diagnostics and
much more precise treatment for the
particular person so there are some
known known genetic mutations actually
which makes sense so there is something
called sglt inhibitor and so these are
actually some um specific Inhibitors
which which block one receptor and help
in treatment of the treatment of
diabetes Now that that receptor the gene
which translates that receptor that that
Gene might be mutated in this particular
section now for the now for those
section that drug may not may not may
not be effective at that much uh level
so that person might need a higher dose
compared to any other person so you can
also make the dosage much more much more
precise compared to a very
sort of a very high level dosage which
we actually do suppose 10 milligrams 20
milligram 30 milligrams so we can maybe
do much more 12.5 milligram or 18.75
milligrams or something so these are all
actually right now in the not in the air
but still but people are working and
people are walking very hard and big
companies are
hitting their heads all day for this
discovery but this is how the things are
going to be in the coming days
now disease prevention now disease
prevention is a is a very uh important
topic and the the module is called as
rising risk prediction so Rising risk
prediction is a very big topic and if
you go and Google Rising this prediction
you will just find out lots of deep
learning models and graph Network models
and regression models which which have
explored millions and billions of
Records that's a really huge data a 3gb
4GB 10 GB files of maybe
one six billion persons who have been
followed for 10 years all the diseases
all the lab investigations unstructured
clinical notes images
ultrasound City scans everything is
there and from there you have to predict
that this person who is suffering from
disease a disease bddc is going to have
developed a disease D in 30 days
or 60 days or one year
now if you can predict predict this
particular thing then you can also
prevent that disease via providing some
preventive modifications some solutions
some management like that so disease
prevention is a very important thing and
it is it is more important given the
lack of Healthcare Resource and because
once the disease sets in then the
healthcare cost just
it it grows exponentially so if so if we
can prevent a disease it's the best
solution in terms of care interest in
terms of costs and in terms of health
and if you if we did if we just see that
the disease at a much later stage then
the cost is high the care is not that
much good and the health burden on that
particular person and Society is also
very high so that's why early disease
prediction prevention is a much uh much
important topic so and just to mention
we are shifting towards value-based
medicine so value-based medicine
actually implies that if you are
treating a patient you should be able to
show me the outcome that I have treated
this thousand patients and the outcome
is that they are having uh out of them I
have I have prevented suppose uh uh 10
of people from getting amputation I have
prevented the hospital admission at
admission rate by 30 percent so these
figures this real and uh very specific
figures thirty percent ten percent so
these things are important in the coming
days and actually insurance companies
will also be paid based on their will
also pay the health providers based on
that particular
based on that particular uh
value based camp
now patient triage I have already told
that so so um when you are having a big
hospital set up with many patients uh
who are in the uh who are in the
uh many domain of suffering from
multiple diseases then you have to
stratify those patients and this is what
we called as patient triage or real
stratification
because in that case you can so in
instead of giving the similar care to
all the patients you can identify that
out of my 100 questions these 15
patients out of high priority and they
have a high risk so I should I should
give more care to these 15 patients so
this is how we can do patient triage and
um then Services then Imaging and
diagnostic I already have told that
nowadays Imaging uh ECGs they all come
with some automated Solutions so we can
do simple predictions from these images
and the and Diagnostics and help and
this is how we can ex we can explore
data science in the domain of healthcare
so next is business process and
management so a healthcare is actually
it's a big it's a big management thing
so there are lots of people that there
are Administration there are Physicians
nut cells then paramedics then maybe the
ambulance drivers and there are lots of
clean
Hospital cleaners and all the staff okay
and and what and there's there's already
something called Automation and business
Process Management
and automation automoting certain things
and they're also it's a very important
role of digital science to uh best to
play there now claims Administration no
claims uh handling claim record
now identifying
fraudulent claims identifying fraudulent
patients so this is also a sort of a
credit card so right it has the same
logic how we so we identify credit card
fraud transactions so because claims
claims industry is a big industry so
it's a very very big industry and so
identifying fraudulent claims it's a
very big task in healthcare
customer churn so we can actually see
that in which season in which location
from which location which specific
patients are coming towards to the
hospital and what is the footfall and
how it goes and goes up and comes down
and how we can increase retention how we
can provide more care maybe decrease the
risk of readmission and all those things
chatbot it's again so right now again
with the increase of healthcare demand
and not that much of increase in the
healthcare resources I mean Physicians
and nurses where there should be some
automated chatbot like Solutions who can
actually provide a very high level or a
very uh preliminary level of
engagement with the patient and last of
all business insights
now the last thing and probably
the most
the most famous or thing among students
or biotech companies are Pharmaceuticals
and so drug Discovery now in this
context drug Discovery is important but
in the context of healthcare you know in
oncology generally we don't find many
patients responding to a particular drug
in any cancer so the idea is to build
was to identify a precise mutation for
those particular patients and to design
a specific drug which can treat the
patient so instead of a just a sort of a
blanket therapy where I give a single
drug to all patients I will try to
identify the type of type of mutation or
mutations or genetic perturbations and
then then I will try to provide design
design a very specific drug for that
particular rotations and that will help
me provide much more precise treatment
planning Logistics and Improvement in
clinical trials so clinical trial is a
very long journey so it takes suppose
phase one then phase two phase three
then phase three B plus four plus five
it's a very long journey so for the drug
to be discovered and the drug to come to
the market it's a very long journey and
people are trying to make it short so as
to patients can take the benefit much
more at a much more earlier stage and
this Improvement of clinical trials we
can also do some mock trials we can do
some trials on the available data we
don't need to we don't we don't need to
redo each and every trial for every
condition and that's where clinical
trial data analytics is very important
which can also help the biotech and
constitutional industry
so this is the very three big big
pillars which I just explained there can
be much more specific pillars uh which
you may come across
now the challenges in both informatics
so we have talked about the
uh the scope uh that is the how it how
is data science going to in going to
informant going to
going to influence the healthcare
industry what are the
various big high levels high level scope
of data science patient care then
business and pharmaceuticals and
automation then now we talk into the
challenges now Healthcare data is
actually
um
so Healthcare data is
anything so it can be so you go to a
doctor and the doctor writes a
prescription uh it's a handwritten
clinical note so it's a healthcare data
and this data still now uh in the
developing countries and there are lots
I still love people right
handed and notes and those are those
actually stay in silos in a very
isolated condition either in a room or
in the patients
covered or or in the file and those data
we can't exploit that data we can't so
for the potential is actually
compromised of that data so and it's a
big challenge even if if we extract that
data using OCR even if the clinical
notes if we convert the clinical nodes
into digital clinical nodes still it is
unstructured so it has no tabular
structure it has it has you know row and
columns or key or values it's it it is
very unstructured and we need to pass it
by using some natural language
processing tasks now this this is not
very easy uh right now but I guess with
the with the advancement of
uh NLP
NLP procedures now chat GPT has also
come with the advancement of birth
models Transformer based models and now
the big shots are coming into this
domain
um Healthcare has might be the next
Target of NLP based based analytics for
data extraction so this is called a data
quality and infrastructure so data
quality means so now there's clinical
notes which which lie suppose in the
software or in your house in a file
there is some lab reports which are in
the lab database there are some Pharmacy
reports which are in the pharmacy
database there are some medicine reports
in the outdoor some in the indoor some
data is your social demographic data
which lies somewhere in the National
Family Health survey portal or whatever
portal you are having so there are lots
of different databases the data is
actually spread across multiple
databases and you have to connect all of
them
to find the real value of this entire
data and you also have social network
data which actually tells about your
mental health and your mental condition
so lots of data scattered here and there
and under different
jurisdictions under different uh
departments so you have to coordinate
the entire thing and get the data and
then clean it and structure it and only
then will you be able to use it for some
predictive modeling and it's a huge task
it's an enormous task you know they have
no idea it's how much how the data
cleaning is a very very important task
in health informatics
so data and the data quality is also a
part because the internet quality might
not be the same across all particular
that was all particular vendors and all
particular providers and all particular
departments
so lack of data quality and lack of
fairness which we called findability
then
interoperability reusability
so lack of fairness and lack of data
quality so the solution what we can tell
so right now what we do is we build
clinical clinical registry so actually
the the problem is that Healthcare data
is not captured with the intention to
capture Healthcare data data is captured
for
as a sub process of care delivery so the
nurses delivered care and in the process
of care they capture some data and
that's all that that data capture
mechanism is not so streamlined not so
structured so the one solution to build
clinical legislation so actually
clinical Registries are built where you
provide care but you also have a very
high priority of
capturing structured data and which will
be fit for scientific Evolution and risk
and we can also develop a proper
ontology for this structuring of our
culture so there is a very huge
database called umlance unified medical
language system and it contains lots and
lots of
ontology and mapping to this and they
designed that and that actually is used
by by most of the companies to do this
data verification
now next is the compliance now
Healthcare data is very private okay so
uh so you can't you can't very easily
get get hold of healthcare data like any
other business data okay so compliance
and governance is very important there
are already complex regulatory
guidelines for healthcare data storage
so anybody can't store data anybody
can't transform your data to to any
facility very easily and HIPAA guideline
is in the iOS in the then gdpr is in the
uh Europe so there are particular
guidelines and does the storage facility
has to be HIPAA compliant and gdpr
compliant only then only they will be
able to
storage
and the solution should be to be
compliance and there's a very complex
solution which is called Affiliated
learning and actually it it exploits so
it's a very Brand New Concept uh not
brand new but it hasn't been so
successfully implemented right now so
where the data will reside in the
particular nursing home or hospital or
the healthcare or the healthcare
space and the model will also be
developed and run from from that data in
the in in the local manner only the
model parameters will be shifted in a
central repository not the data just the
model parameters and there will be a two
and pro journey of the model parameters
so the parameters would be collected
from multiple hospitals then there would
be aggregation and then again a d
distribution so the data won't reside in
any Central server the data would be
residing locally in all the hospitals
the predictive models would be running
locally in all the hospitals but the
parameter generation and testing and
aggregation and redistribution would be
just
occurring in the central depository so I
would suggest everybody just to just to
give a high level just to just go go
through a high leveling of faded
learning and it's a very uh
A New Concept it's a very interesting
concept and people may get
much more interesting in it and lastly
even if we have data quality maintained
even if we we had data compliance issues
solved then that is data science skill
length so we actually lack lots of data
literacy so the healthcare workers the
nurses Physicians they are not at all
and data data literate or
computationally very expert so they have
no idea of how to explode the data how
to use the data for their own purpose
and like okay and the other way we also
have much more skilled and data analysts
but they don't understand the complexity
of healthcare domain so there we need to
form a bridge so we need either we need
to we need the healthcare workers to be
more learn it in and literate
all we need skilled data analysts who
have the understanding of healthcare
movement complexity
and this is where we need ah we need and
they need knowledge and skill set of
various various different data sources
and type apps broad Health informatics
and this is where actually the course
has been
conceived and formulated form
now
use cases uh I will just go touch upon
the use cases which form under the under
the big umbrella of electric informatics
so Health informatics can start with
Predictive Analytics so a patient having
certain diseases that patient might have
a sudden cardiac attack might have a
fall might have a chance of getting
hospitalized so if we can predict that
event prior to its happening and if you
can put and that that part that
particular person on high disk ladder
may be put that person on as a high
alert alert patient and accordingly
monitor them so so that the event
doesn't occur or even if the event
occurs we can very quickly and swiftly
move that person to a particular
facility and give very urgent and
proactive care
to that particular person so this is
called creative analytics and that this
can be multiple things we will talk upon
talk upon touch upon one particular use
case in this particular course but that
can there can be multiple use cases in
this particular domain
cluster identification so Healthcare in
healthcare we have lots of lots of
patients we have lots and lots of
positions so if we can have a data
science and look at the data that which
physician has been has seen which
particular patient in which the date and
what what and what was the outcome so
from there we're gonna we're gonna
cluster the positions that these
Physicians this particular cluster of
Physicians are very trained in treating
migraine
or this particular cluster of position
are very trained in in creating epilepsy
and this cluster actually will treat
type 2 diabetes very good for this
particular age group
so we can determine cluster of
Physicians from the healthcare data in
the same manner we may have some data of
the patients and we can tell that this
particular age group of patients who are
majorly male and who have a very
peculiar type of dietary pattern more
commonly present with disease a b c and
b so let's modify uh their diet in a
very precise way
on the other cluster might have a
different pattern of Health
problems so one plaster can be having
mental health problem with diabetes one
cluster diabetes and hypertension one
cluster having a another diabetes with
hypothyroid and we can actually
detect those clusters and maybe we can
cater much more specific medication
according
now time series analysis so nowadays all
of us are actually we use fitbits we use
variables so we can just stream the live
stream the data coming from the Fitbit
the heart rate blood pressure and all
those things and the heart rate goes up
when we are having some exercise the
heart rate also goes up when we are
having some problem pathologically so if
we can detect that pathological
condition from time series data and
again so once we detect once we predict
that this person is going to have an
incident heart attack or an incident or
an incident acute asthmatic attack then
we can either prevent it or we can
either or what you can coordinate the
resources in such a way that proper care
is rendered at a much earlier stage and
the patient is not ignored until a very
very late stage so you can use time
series models for the for that
particular
purpose
we can do image analytics where we can
automate CT scan reports x-ray reports
MRI reports and even video there are
also colonoscopy endoscopy and USD which
are actually video files you can also
classify those video files for that for
this for this purpose we can detect a
handwritten clinical notes and we can
apply NLP based rules and models to
extract data structure them and then
find insights from the particular so we
can take suppose 1000
descriptions from One hospital and
thousand from other Hospital maybe at
two different months of the year we can
do the extraction and we can see that
which is the most commonly prescribed
drug in that hospital in that month
which are the more most commonly
co-occurred in conditions for a
particular age group which is the most
commonly which is the more most common
month for the increase of dengue in a
particular region so you can do multiple
types of analytics if we can explore
that particular field using NLP and all
and you can of course customize those
models we can combine predictable
analytics we can combine image with
handwritten and time series to do to do
a prediction and there are lots of lots
of scopes for this so just to give three
examples so as I just told before also
we can subtype a particular cancel and
we can identify specific gene
perturbations or gene mutations for a
cancer group and we can cater a very
specific precise therapy we can detect
and classify tumors from x-ray or CT
scan or MRI images
from from mental health because mental
health is actually a very chronic
condition mental health conditions like
anxiety depression which lead to Suicide
or severe depression when the person
gives up everything
he has less appetite doesn't eat doesn't
sleep loses interest in job and
relationships and friends and
occupational profession so these mental
health conditions we can predict from
The Social Network boosts from the from
different facial
expressions there are lots of
opportunities so we can the facial
expression the facial gauge the posts
which they are doing in the industrial
Network we can analyze them to predict
and even the voice quality the the voice
quality over the phone you can just
exploit to do a mental health prediction
so there are lots of possible just
wanted to give you a very and diverse
sort of
explanation or exposure here
how does a predictive model actually
look like so so now now as you already
know there would be different types of
sources that would be ehrs which are
electronic health records digital
records unstructured records majorly
there would be Wireless variables so
fitbits and remote position modern
devices Apple fitbits and Samsung
fitbits medical devices that can be SPO
to monitor that can be other ECG
home-based ECG monitors
clinical notes can be handwritten
Pharmacy records what the drug the
patient has received for the last one
year two year three year in the in the
pharmacy uh dead in the database lab
investigations for all the tests and the
values
publicly available database which tells
you that suppose this question comes
from a particular state or for a
particular County and that county has a
literacy rate of that much that much
percent that county has a dietary
pattern of this this these so publicly
available databases can also be used for
that particular purpose and you can also
ask send regular service that how is
your mood how how are you feeling to the
particular person and they can also
reply and we can just collect
information so all the information can
be clubbed together in a in a database
of course
complying with regulations and this is a
very big task and this is called as dead
data preparation
so once we do the data preparation we
can again explode the features we can
explore the student growing features we
can explore the comorbidities we can
export the lifestyle habits the
self-tech and surveys the real-time
vitals from the fitbits so you can
explore all the different groups of
features
and then we can feature engineer this
particular feature groups and then we
can feed them into a trading training uh
split them into training and validation
and we can fit them into a machine
learning model
now this machine learning model will
receive the training set and we it will
adjust the parameters of the model and
there is a very intricate mathematics in
this particular modeling and that also
differs from one to other model and this
machine learning model will be tested
will be cross validated and it will
arrive to a particular
to a particular
accuracy and sensitivity and specificity
we we will talk about all these things
more specifically in the Hands-On case
studies
now this model we can use to predict
length of State prediction suppose a
patient gets hospitalized when the
patient gets hospitalized we take all
the information and we predict that this
patient is going to stay for 10 days
or this for five days or this for seven
days well this for two days so you can
do this prediction we can predict
chronic disease risk so this patient
operation suffering from these five
diseases have a risk of developing a six
disease in the coming six months so
let's prevent that we can just have a
have some clinical division
a patient gets released from the
hospital so what is the chance of that
patient again getting re-admitted we can
predict
once a patient goes through a surgery
maybe a minor surgery
what is the risk of developing
post-operative complications so if the
patient is diabetic the surgical site
has not killed within the first six
hours and if there is some fuss coming
out and the patient already have some I
said comorbidity so you can predict if
the patient is having a bring other post
or complications we can predict multiple
parameters that the patient is going to
have an impending heart attack or
impending acute asthmatic attack from
the vital parameters and also mental
health outcome prediction so we can that
there could be lots and lots of other
clinical outcomes I just mentioned a few
here
and we can also customize the model now
just to mention in healthcare domain
there's something called false positive
and false false negative so false
positive means the model has told that
this person has a disease but that
person doesn't have a disease and false
negative means the model has told the
person is normal or healthy but the
person is actually not healthy the
person is unhealthy now in healthcare we
always strike to increase the false
negative the false positivity at the
expense of uh reduced false negativity
because we don't want a person who is
actually having the disease
to be diagnosed as healthy we can bear
with a person who is healthy
to be diagnosed as healthy because that
that then the person would be taken
forward and screened and then the person
would be discovered as healthy but if we
if the model tells that the person is
actually healthy and so the false
negative rate we always try to decrease
and when the false native bread is
decreased generally the false positive
actually increases so we so that in
healthcare models we always try to
increase the false uh decrease the false
negative debt at the cost of an
increased first false positive rate so
that's something just keep in mind in
healthcare false negative blood should
be minimized even if the false positive
rate is actually much more higher that's
not a big big problem in healthcare
and now now when the new data comes from
this again root it goes to the model and
then does the prediction and now the
most important part maybe in healthcare
is featured important coding so a
healthcare domain is actually what the
Physicians the nurses they also want
some extraordination that why is this
model predicting that this person will
be having a will develop this particular
three diseases why now this is something
called interpretable AI now the model
has to store some kitchen importance has
to has to go through some interpretable
AI solution which will tell that this
model has predicted these three diseases
for this new person because of this this
reason
so it will give an interpretation of the
prediction and that's very important for
healthcare
decision making
now uh I am almost the last slide I
guess so just to introduce these um this
approach to you all so that this is
known as multi-modal approach called
cohesion medicine so I guess I have
covered it on multiple occasions during
the entire presentation
so we have different type of records
from a same patient and you can do
different predictions and this is where
we do multi-modal data Fusion so we
concatenate we merge different data
types across all the databases and that
goes into a data interconnection that
increases the cost the complexity and
invasiveness of course but that again
helps in much more precise helps to take
much small range of features for the
prediction and we can also do
multi-modal interpretability
and do some quantitative analysis then
we can do Sim supervised learning
unsupervised learning we can do bamaka
exploration and we can translate all the
models to practice so it's a big Journey
not so simple as I just told but
actually the healthcare industry is
moving towards multimodal data Fusion
while people are trying to use
multi-modal data to predict a particular
clinical outcome and these multimodal
data ranges from uh unstructured
clinical notes to time series data to
genomics data to proteomics data to
transcriptomics data to family history
to the treatment received and everything
so this is actually going and going to
be a very integrative field and it will
maybe translate into something called
biomedical informatics which will take
bioinformatics as well as Healthcare
informatics
emerge in the coming Days by this name
so uh
that being told I this is so this is the
last slide of mine and uh so these are
the models and so we can develop models
in the lab by using the data claims data
homics data structure data image data
clinical notes but actually these models
need to be validated there has to be
internal validation external validation
prospective validation because we need
to see if actually in actually in the
prospective validation it is happening
or not local testing
randomized control tile so it's validity
also usability so how how how use and
how usable and how users finish the
model is so uh if so we also have to
develop a very cool interface very
usable interface which can be accessed
via a smartphone or maybe at Max tab
because not actually not at all a laptop
or a desktop because which which has to
be usable by every healthcare worker
and also the utility if if using that if
interpreting that particular model is
actually helping to decrease the risk of
date of admission to decrease the
mobility and mortality so it has to we
also have to have to prove the utility
and that also will we can prove via some
RCT where we can randomly
integrate one model to one particular
arm and not integrate one into
particular arm and see how the utility
comes comes out and then leave then only
it will arrive to a clinical impact and
we can
take the model to deployment and
clinical decision making and this is the
big gap this might look like a small Gap
but this is a very very very big and I
guess we will be able to uh solve it in
the coming days
so with that I would like to end my
talk today and now I am open for
questions
thank you so much sir uh so the
participants have any queries uh please
share it in the chat and we will need to
answer
we have a query from uh CL uh he's
asking how much does it cost for the or
procedures for a patient
so I'm pasting the query in the chat
once
there are also some questions
um there's one question by chirag so
okay so how much does it cost for all
the procedures for a patient okay so
this will again depend on the particular
disease or the particular symptoms
so this would be much so if we just want
to do a very plain
genomics of one particular patient so
the the cost of doing a deep sequencing
has reduced over the last one decade it
would have been close to 60 or 70 000 to
get the entire genome profiled in INR
but right now I guess it can be around
30 35
000 for a genome profiling but again
it's not about the uh the cost it's not
a blanket cost it will again so if we
are studying it's not very case specific
so if we are trying to predict
that which diabetes patients will
develop chronic kidney disease in the
coming two years then we have to
um we have to do those tests we have to
design the study to include those tests
which detect diabetes which detect
chronic kidney disease and so forth we
can't it's not possible to do every test
for Every patient so it depends on the
research question at Large
Okay so
are the jobs
in the field related to Diagnostic and
Analysis of disease or they include job
type of data scientists or
database formation like typical jobs so
I guess whatever you have mentioned in
your message everything is on the on
your plane can be on your plate okay so
I will tell you so so the first is that
database management so the healthcare
database management is a very
specialized field
that's something which people having the
expertise of dbms and database
management may be typical IP jobs they
will be doing
data scientists would and then there's
something called Data
data
transcription and detached translation
medical transcriptionist the the person
actually
[Music]
structures the clinical data and the
person is very well versed with clinical
entities and clinical coding and how to
how to how to map one disease how to map
six different names to a single name and
in and in that way there's the the role
of the medical transcriptionist and then
there's a data scientist who will be
applying models
by taking all these structured data and
that scientist will also have to
structure the data on his or her own
part
and so that's the thing so the
healthcare data scientist is what uh
might be the
top uh top of the of the pyramid but I
guess it would fall under the purview of
any IP solution which has
solution solution architect database
data structuring
team and data prediction team so it will
operate more like a it solution actually
but the
problem should be much more data science
Healthcare Healthcare specific so you
would also need some some healthcare
domain expert some clinical domain
expert who will provide you the clinical
Outlook
[Music]
is included
post treatment do we make any assessment
of those who have been released from the
healthcare passwords after a month or
few
this is to see at least if they were
dissatisfied
this can be done this can be done so uh
so when so when the person is released
from a particular facility then we
should be having a prediction of the
re-admission risk in the coming 30 days
and the assessment of the post-operative
complications that person might
develop in the coming 30 days and also
the level of satisfaction this also we
can detect via some via some service
where the what that person will be doing
some coding and then we can again
increase the patient compliance the to
the particular facility but again these
things are not at all ready operating
right now might be in bits and pieces
for one or two facilities the entire
thing is actually in the in discussion
and in trial mode and people are trying
from the Academia so it's not again it's
very embryonic it's very very important
actually
um so that's that's where the potential
and opportunity lies
specific guide techniques that can be
used for better diagnosis and prognosis
in the lab and what are the cost
effectivity of business the cost of
activating is actually good so um a
specific editing so we so uh so actually
Healthcare data is something called uh
non-independent so it's very dependent
data suppose for one particular patient
for a particular visit the patient
receives some drugs
has some diagnosis may receive some
procedures some some operation or
something so and that patient will may
have multiple visits So the patient's
data is interdependent on that
particular patient so in this case and
deep learning based models and there is
one particular modeling technique which
people are using multi-health
self-attention models and these models
are very much into the space right now
and again the effectivity because now
the problem is in order to integrate a
healthcare AI model into the healthcare
you have to go through the RCT procedure
and actually people are telling you have
to get a FDA approval that this model is
going to treat patients now we haven't
yet reached to that particular skill so
we called it as assisted Solutions which
will assist the particular person
but days are coming that they will be
going to to uh through a very uh wide uh
scope and wide implementation
thank you so how should a public health
professional fit into Healthcare
informatics public health professional
is actually uh
uh public health is actually a lots of
data just to tell you I started my
journey from Public Health Data so in
India that there's something called
National Family Health survey not in
India so it's a part of a global program
called demographic DHS you can go to the
DHS site there are lots of lots of data
so large files 3gb 6gb 74 and 20 GB
files okay and so the entire population
and so I I remember my first data set
had eight lakh rows and almost 5000
columns okay so it it was very tough to
open in uh in a very small laptop so uh
and from there you can so I have one
paper which from that particular data so
there we identify type 2 diabetes
clusters and each cluster had a very
specific dietary habit and there are
very specific
anthropometry and those clusters are
actually from there we can detect those
clusters and given a new patient with
the diabetes comes we should actually
provide a very specific
lifestyle modification for diabetes so
nowadays we just give a very blanket so
anybody with the diabetes this is the
recommendation that shouldn't be the
case there are there are very specific
forms of diabetes and you have to
provide the recommendation keeping in
mind those specific forms and so again
publicly professional I guess is the
is we'll be having a very easy route or
easy entry to help informatics from that
perspective
How could a university student do
something in biomedical AI technique
so I am not sure how could a university
student means at which level is the
person a BSC or MSC or PhD
everybody's English student so to start
with you should and
start with one question
one data set there are lots of publicly
available with data set we will I will
actually introduce you in the next
session I guess to almost 30 publicly
available reports which are having more
than one million of on data sets
structured unstructured and whatnot and
you could just download all those are
downloadable just download uh one or two
of them and have your own question and
then you can implement it
are there any success stories of using
models
and there are and just to be just to be
very
so just tell you this very upfront so uh
Healthcare informatics as you know it's
a very um
it's because Healthcare data is very
tightly regulated it's very scarce
anybody can anybody can't access
Healthcare data so and the healthcare
models and the solutions are also very
private
so in our company also we built a
healthcare models so the success depends
to success we can taste internally
we might not use those model for the
clinical decision support but that
definitely the models help us to
generate insights and to
design or to um the course of the
company and how how should the insurance
provider
behave how can we prevent these diseases
how can you how can we provide a more uh
better quality of care to reduce risk of
getting hospitalized and thereby to
reduce the health care costs so this we
can do and this we actually do but these
are actually very private data sets and
so there are
uh are there any further questions sir I
think most of them are direct messages
[Music]
I see here
so uh so I would just uh I'll just
encourage you all that and
first to conceive one particular
question so
in healthcare because it's like it's
it's like a forest so
so if you go to a forest you will be
getting lots of Trades trees lots of
species lots of animals and you might
not you might get confused okay
so if it's a forest at least narrow down
your uh your search that I would like to
search I would like to limit my search
to these four species of plants and five
species of animals just try to
specifically design a question
data is available I we will talk about
the data and we will I will show you
that those all those data
repos and how can we access those data
how can we structure the data
um but first of all we need to make the
question more specific so once we make
the question then of course because if
you don't come from Healthcare
background even if you come from
Healthcare background
for one particular question you need to
have a sense of the health care problem
that if you are if you work with
diabetes at least what is diabetes
what are the risk factors of diabetes so
very very basic things that we can also
guide you we just need to know because
unless you have the knowledge of the
disease you can't build a model
successfully because you also need to
interpret the model
and once you have the question in your
mind you get the data then you go
through some very basic level of disease
understanding then you start to explode
the data then you start to build the
model then test the model then extend
the model so it's a very four steps data
exploration
then so data preparation data
exploration model building and model
interpretation
so these four steps will actually cover
everything but you need to narrow down
your particular clinical research
question
thank you so much sir a wonderful
session uh and now for those
participants who are not enrolled for
the program yet some of them have shared
their email IDs in the chat box uh rest
of them also
um you can share me your email ID either
through direct message and also for the
program uh details and registration
costs now I'd like to invite it's past
that to introduce the marketplace
overdose
thank you so much SRI gauri and uh thank
you so much Dr Jeet zakar it was a
really wonderful and a comprehensive
session though
so uh I'll just quickly share my screen
and guide you all through the
registration process
so shikori can you please uh confirm if
my screen is visible
yes it is good perfect
so this is the program page and I'm
sharing the link here in the chat box
also with everyone
so uh the first session was today and
those who haven't enrolled for this
program yet they can enroll now also and
we are offering everyone up to a 50
scholarship
so
um yeah those who are interested they
can ping their uh email address in the
chat box and one of our representative
word no down and send you the associated
uh scholarship link as well as the steps
to register yourself so once you'll
scroll down you can see a program
overview what uh things we'll be
covering in the program how we'll be
proceeding further
so obviously uh the name of the program
is machine learning for health
informatics
we will be you will be utilizing medical
informatics data so as to apply data
science and machine learning techniques
which will impact there will be a
positive impact between a patient and a
physician relationship so there would be
a case-based learning on that there
would be surely a mentor guidance
through q a sessions through one-on-one
sessions or group-like sessions we will
be transiting each and every participant
who is not from the background of Health
informatics from a beginner level to an
advanced level and through the data
acquisition data structuring workflow
selection and cross validation for
healthcare and clinical data analysis
steps now here we'll be including
analysis of different data types uh on
different on data different data sources
in health informatics like electronic
health records diagnostic test results
medical scans and biomedical data and
their integration with the healthcare
research
in the end we will be providing we will
be guiding students about different
opportunities for participants in this
particular field whether it is a job
opportunity Etc career guidance and
about the certification also now when
you'll scroll down you can see our
interactive session or interactive
sessions a calendar where there are a
few dates highlighted so the very first
session was today on 11 and the next
session is on Saturday 14th we will be
sharing the calendar invitation for
those who have already enrolled and for
those who haven't you can enroll till uh
14 and you'll also receive the calendar
invite accordingly so today we covered
the first
session that is Introduction to the
program and here are some of the topics
which we covered a brief description
about the inventor was there AI in
transforming Healthcare investments in
AI for healthcare how data science is
transforming Healthcare challenges in
healthcare informatics predictive model
workflow
multi-modal approach for precision
medicine and and in the end there was a
q a session also now the second session
that is on January 14th uh is on data
sources and the topics which we'll be
covering of oh there will be a quick
recap of the of today's session then
we'll be talking about data sources
health records Imaging data
sorry
okay Imaging data histopathological data
multiomics data and some miscellaneous
data and in the end there would be q a
session again so as you'll scroll down
you can see each and every top each and
every session and uh Associated uh their
topics which we'll be covering per
session
foreign
further
when you scroll down you can see there
are three different tenures which you
can opt for one is 45 60 and then 90. so
there are some common resources which
you will have access to once you will
enroll in the program that are online
tutorials project example scoring
session session recordings online Mentor
Support Online technical support
certificate after completion and then
example of cloud pipelines on day
bioinfo server now there is a difference
between the three tenures uh in first
tenure that is 45 days you will be like
you will be training yourself like there
would be a full-fledged training in 60
days with training you will have extra
15 days to work on your research
proposal presented to the mentor for
evaluation purpose and get a feedback
from the mentor so as to make your
proposal more validated and further you
can move with the research project
formulation or experimental design also
now uh this third is the 90 days tenure
and in 90 days tenure you will have
access to 45 days of training plus 45
days of independent research project
with access to one-on-one mental
sessions now the outcome for 90 days is
a poster presentation obviously in
research Symposium or any other
International Conference or it's a
research publication in a good
peer-reviewed Journal now as you can see
uh the pricing for uh now it is
reflecting on my screen is in USD
dollars those who are from different
location for example you are from
Nigeria or you are from India or from us
or Europe Etc you can change your uh
uh the currency according to your
location I just show you the pricing in
USD now I'm changing it into INR and
once I change into INR you can see that
for 45 days the pricing is INR 7500 for
60 it's
10 000 and for 90 it's 15 000 and again
we are providing with scholarships up to
50 percent and those who are interested
they can uh they they can ping their
email address in the chat box and one of
our representative would mail them with
the scholarship details as well as the
steps to register now how one can
proceed with the payment checkup for
example if I'm interested in 45 days or
60 or 90 days I'll slip slip simply
click on buy now button
whatever coupon code the representative
will provide you with you need to Simply
type the coupon code over here click on
the apply button the coupon code applied
successfully notification will pop up
here on the screen then you need to fill
out your user details that is your name
email address phone country occupation
organization Etc
click on this check box and then select
payment method either stripe or PayPal
and then if you choose stripe then you
need to submit your card details if you
choose PayPal then you need to proceed
accordingly so this is how one can
proceed with the payment checkout option
all uh also there are different payment
options available for Indian uh
participants or Indian Community then
same for Nigerian community and then
same for those who are
from a U.S Canada UK Germany or turkey
turkey
Etc so there are bank transfer details
available there are upis available
uh so yeah so this was all about the
registration part the scholarship part
the resources which will have access to
the difference between the three tenures
and uh
the next session uh which is commencing
from on 14th and it's curriculum so if
anyone is having any doubt related to
the registration part or any other so
please feel free to Ping in the chat box
and I'll be there to answer your query
thank you over to you SRI gauri
thank you so much
um so does anyone have any query
uh Hamza is asking for those of us from
low and middle income countries is there
any full-funded scholarship
so Hamza uh definitely there are
different options available for those
who are from middle income countries uh
one uh so please share your email
address here in the chat box we will
share a scholarship form with you so
that you can fill out that particular
form and we can discuss this with uh our
internal team and then accordingly get
back to you of how much scholarship you
can provide or if it's a fully funded
scholarship then there are some
particular Majors which we'll seek for
and if you clarify those uh Majors then
definitely you can proceed further with
the fully funded scholarship
thank you so much so does anyone have
any further queries so please let me
know in the chat
otherwise we will be ending today's
session
I'll pause for a couple of seconds
uh I'm once again sharing the email ID
and the contact number uh of our team so
that you can reach out to us at any time
uh if you're having any queries uh
Mukesh is asking debit card will valid
for payment
yeah definitely the debit card is also
valid for payment uh so but yes there's
one uh it depends the version of the
debit card whether it is a Visa or a
MasterCard so we can sort this out
definitely but debit card is also
applicable so as to do the payment
if it doesn't work for example debit
card while you're proceeding with the
payment you can simply ping us at a
marketing at the rate omixtlogic.com and
we can provide you with different or
other payment options available with us
thank you so much guys so I guess if the
participants have no further queries um
we're good to end today's session so
that I look forward to seeing you all
for the second session of the program
where we will be discussing about the
area of data sources and with that thank
you everyone for joining today's session
and have a great day thank